my good morning everyone
welcome to this simultaneous meeting of
baby district council cabinet
and mid-suffolk district council cabinet
i am councillor john ward leader of
weber district council
and also in attendance to my right as
councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk
we will jointly be chairing the meeting
today however for reasons of efficiency
i will be leaving the items may i remind
you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons in the
chamber
and in the social areas please ensure
that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or if you're
unable to do so and that you use the
hand sanitizer and wipes provided
please maintain social distancing at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak or persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov
app i would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
who have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded
i'd like now to move to the agenda
please so item one
apologies for absence good morning chair
we have seen
uh apologies from councillor davis thank
you
item two to receive declarations of
machinery and non-pecuniary interest by
members
are there any to declare
item three then uh is the first paper
we're moving on to paper bca219
to confirm the minutes of the baby
cabinet meeting held on the 8th of june
2021. i'll just go through these
page by page paper members page 9.
page ten page eleven
page twelve page thirteen
so was that page twelve council buzzfeed
yep
uh top line nine 9.7 yep i've been
converted to council are busy
now oh you have yes i know i'm a busy
bee but it's the bee that's missing
it is yeah thank you for that that's the
busby
page 13.
page 14 page 15
page 16 and finally page 17.
okay so there are no further questions
may i have a proposal please
counselor busby and a seconder
councillor halt where we conduct the
electronic vote please
yes if members could go to the
electronic vote on their app
and scroll down to the blue line the mem
the vote is now
in progress
so
chair that is seven votes four
thank you councilmember
the item mca 21-8 is to confirm the
minutes of the mid-suffolk cabinet
meeting held on the 7th of june
do we have any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
page 7 page 8
page 9.
10
page 11
page 12.
can i have a proposal please
happy to propose thank you councillor
flatman and can i have a second to
please
councillor headingham thank you very
much and i'll now ask the government's
officer to conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair um councillors if you
could please open the vote in the
modern.gov app by clicking the plus sign
in the top right of the agenda screen
and select
attendance and voting the vote will now
be in progress
under the favor minutes
chair that is nine votes full
thank you moving on to item four
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the castle's petition
scheme
none received thank you item five
questions by councillors
you chair we have received questions
from council jameson and council lindsay
i will read out the these there are
three questions two from councillor
jameson
and one from councillor lindsay i'll
read out each question
and following the question i'll ask
councillor halt
a cabinet member for the economy to
respond
so councilor jameson's first question
the bid for external funding that was
made for the park entrance
was this the bid for funding from the
land release fund if it was
what land did we intend to release for
the housing development
the land related to the bellevue house
being brought back into residential use
and the old swimming pool site question
mark castle halt
thank you chair the bid was submitted
prior to any marketing
of the site and due to the criteria of
the bid
had to be drafted on the assumption
there would be housing on the old
swimming pool site
and a refurbishment of the house as
residential
this was an assumption made only for the
purpose
of the bid and had no impact on the open
and transparent marketing
process of the site
thank you council hall the next question
how are baba going to remedy the open
space deficit in sudbury when they are
disposing of the open space that it does
have
provision of new public open space part
of the new park entrance
means that only a very small percentage
of public
open space will be lost due to the
recent sale of the adjacent site
it's important to recognize that there
are a range of different types of open
space
ranging from accessible natural green
space to
more formal parks and gardens there will
be significant new open space associated
with
chilton woods
thank you councillor and finally
councillor lindsay's question
the contract with the retirement homes
developer says that the contract will
not complete
by we will not get payment until
planning permission is granted
it also says that we don't have to start
work on the retaining wall and entrance
until
after completion within three months so
why do we need to borrow money to do the
retaining wall works before we have
planning permission
and before the sale to the developer
completes
thank you there will be a need to ensure
we have forward funding monies
for before completion of the churchill
contract
as the lead time or the leading time
actually commences works
on site is several months before the
retaining wall is linked into the wider
park entrance scheme
and new cafe and toilets and for all
of those elements we will need to
appoint professional design team
including next level of design
and structural stroke party wall
assessments
submit a plan application independent to
that being submitted by churchill
and run a tender process for a
contractor
if we do not start this work prior to
completion of the churchill contract
we will have insufficient time to meet
the contract obligations
to start on the site within three months
thank you councillor holt
next item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
thank you chair the joint ovu and scruti
committee has forwarded recommendations
from the meeting that was held on monday
the 28th of june
okay councilor william yes thank you
chair
um this is the item um
the scrutiny review of the joint parking
strategy process
and timeline at the joint overview and
scrutiny committee meeting on the 28th
of june members can
consider the report from cassandra
clements the assistant director
for environment and commercial
partnerships
the assistant director pointed out that
since the report had been written the
use of a specialist consultant
to undertake much of the data collection
and consultation work
had been considered and it was now
proposed for those elements of the
process to be undertaken by external
consultants
this would enable several tasks to be
carried out simultaneously
the time scale for the work would be
significantly reduced
members considered that the final report
should be presented to cabinet in june
2022 rather than june
rather sorry rather than december 2022
members considered the proposed
stakeholder engagement list
and made a number of suggested editions
which are listed in the recommendation
which you have before you
i would like to draw your attention
cabinet's attention to the role that a
parking strategy
can play in encouraging walking cycling
and the use of public transport
the committee urged cabinet to instruct
officers to investigate
issues around the introduction of
residence parking schemes in both
districts
including the potential for committing
finance to such a scheme
thank you
thank you council welcome do any cabinet
members from either babel mid suffolk
have any
questions
castle holt i'll just pick up on a
comment ready
i'm pleased to hear that it's been
brought forward six months from december
to
the june i think it's a very important
um program that we're undertaking here
and i think it's uh
you know the quicker we get the feedback
on it the better for everyone
yes thank you i agree with that um
if there are no further questions oh
casa osborne
thank you mr chairman yeah i also am
pleased to see that it's been brought
forward if we've got consultants
involved we
you know we will tell them a timeline
and they can keep to that timeline so i
was pleased to see that
obviously it goes to cabinet briefing i
think
excuse me on the 2nd of august i will be
discussing that
just one just one comment i was a little
bit surprised that
bearing in mind the problems that we've
got in the district and i'm sure you've
got the same in mid suffolk
about people parking on green verges and
green open space
areas that this wasn't identified
as something for discussion at cabinet
so i'm i shall be raising that myself
when it comes to cabinet
thank you mr chairman thank you
counselor
if there are no um further questions
then uh thank you councilman rodin for
your report
and uh we'll pick up on that when it
comes to cabinet
so item seven next is the forthcoming
decisions list
does anyone have any questions on the
content of that
we've all had a chance to see it several
times so
if not then i will
move on
okay then item eight paper bca 2110
and paper mca 21-9 the leisure sport and
physical activity strategy
i'll now invite the mid-suffolk cabinet
member for health and well-being to
introduce the mid-suffolk report
thank you very much chair i'm delighted
to introduce this report
which is the refreshed leisure sport and
physical activity strategy for both
baber and mid suffolk district councils
since the council's lspa strategy was
adopted in 2017
significant change has taken place both
in terms of investment and delivery of
developed
of development identified in the
strategy but in addition there have been
numerous changes at a national regional
and regional and local level that we
must take into account
in mid suffolk for example we've
invested 1.2 million
in gym facilities at mid-south leisure
centre 200 000 for the refurbishment of
stradbroke swimming pool and fitness
centre
and 60 000 in gym facilities at
development sports and leisure centre
alongside this considerable funding has
been provided to village halls
sports grounds and facilities and
voluntary community and social
enterprise organizations to enhance
facilities
and increase opportunities for local
people to participate in a wide range of
activities that promote fitness
health and wellbeing and other aspects
of people's lives
through our community grant scheme and
section 106 funding across the two
districts
in addition numerous substantial changes
at a wider level include
the new projected housing numbers across
both districts from the emerging
joint local plan changes in how people
are participating in exercise and using
facilities
they've been two important national
publications that have highlighted
changes
to participation trends in both the
structure and forms of sport leisure
and physical exercise similarly the
impact of kobit 19
also means that there needs to be a
greater focus on how clubs and
activities can recover
after the pandemic and secure their
long-term sustainability
finally the refreshed strategy will also
be a key part
of the new well-being strategy with
strong links as well to
our community strategy in response to
these changes the refresh of the
strategy will help
to establish an overall vision for the
future of sport and physical activity in
baber and mid-suffolk
it will define the required strategic
outcomes or end results
it will identify the strategic
objectives that need to be achieved to
help get
the right results and will develop the
specific actions required
to meet the objectives and to support
delivery
the strategic outcomes and supporting
strategic objectives fall into
three distinct but interrelated themes
which form the building blocks of the
updated
strategy these are what outcomes do the
councils
want to see and for whom what
infrastructure places and spaces are
needed to contribute to these outcomes
and who are the key partners and
enablers and how should we work
with them to help contribute to these
outcomes
in terms of the six strategic outcomes
themselves
these are reduced levels of inactivity
among communities and
localities experiencing greater health
inequalities
increased opportunities for all
residents to move through an
accessible diverse and inclusive
programme of activities
sustainable community sport leisure and
physical activity facilities that enable
and support all residents to be active
green and open spaces providing formal
and informal opportunities
for all residents to be every day active
a strong sustainable and strategically
aligned ecosystem of partnerships
supporting all residents to be more
active and finally a skilled
knowledgeable and enabled workforce and
volunteer base
supporting communities to be more active
in terms of the strategy itself
in addition to the a significant
infrastructure pipeline
outlined in section 7.3 of the strategy
we've also have numerous leisure
and well-being schemes that are ongoing
these range from our active schools
program
to our active well-being scheme which is
aimed at people over the age of 50 who
are inactive
and are also working with gp surgeries
and others to encourage social
prescribing
as i hope you can see a substantial
amount of work has gone into the refresh
of this strategy
including comprehensive analysis of
supply and demand across the district
and extensive stakeholder engagement
which is set out in appendices b and c
of this report
in particular we've had direct
engagement with a broad range of clubs
and societies
including 44 strategic stakeholders 11
sports
sporting national governing bodies and
have had more than 250 responses
to bespoke surveys which is considerably
higher than the
previous engagement for the 2017
strategy
although branded as a as a refresh this
strategy represents a substantial amount
of work
and i would like to add my personal
thanks to both officers and
the sport leisure and culture
consultancy for their efforts in in such
an enormous undertaking
and on that positive note i'm very happy
to propose the recommendations that have
in section three of the report
and hope that both cabinets will support
it thank you chair
thank you very much that councillor
richardson may i have a seconder from
mid-suffolk please
flowers very happy to second the
um paper
this council is determined to invest
in our physical our residents physical
well-being and mental health well-being
and as you can see by the investment
that has just been read out
we're taking this very seriously and the
refresh has come at just the right time
when we're all very aware of what the
pandemic has left on our doorstep for us
to cope with
and we will carry on doing so thank you
very much jen
thank you castle flatman in the absence
of the
baylor cabinet member for communities
who unfortunately are able to be
present uh and here with us today i just
wanted to say a few words
um from a baby perspective on on this
paper um
clearly uh we we've already been
investing um quite a bit
uh since the original strategy was
adopted in 2017.
um specifically in weber they're two big
projects and we've invested over two
million pounds in building the new
swimming facilities in hadley
and 2.4 million pounds in an extension
and refurbishment of the kingfisher
leisure center in sudbury
there's also been considerable funding
provided to village halls sports grounds
facilities
and voluntary community and social
enterprise organizations
so that they can enhance their
facilities and increase opportunities
for
local residents
just a quick word about hadley pool i
went there on friday for the official
opening
and um it's an amazing facility it
really is
something that a town as small as hadley
to have a facility like that they should
be really proud
and i know it is getting used uh very
much and it's
it's absolutely wonderful to see but
um having spent all that money in
sudbury and hadley
we do want to focus on the whole of the
district
particularly in the east over towards
the shotley peninsula
and in the center of the district we
know that we've got population pressures
in brampton
capital and east berggold and we do need
to
try to improve the facilities in those
locations and we want to work with our
schools
and all with schools both public uh
the state schools and also the
independent schools
because we do have two independent
schools within the district in the east
who
we can hopefully work with there are a
number of priority infrastructure
projects that we've listed
and that we want to proceed with those
and we've got to all sorts of funding
sources community grants locality awards
sill
and then we work with partners and also
the ability to seek external funding so
i'm happy to propose this paper from a
baby perspective
and i'd like to ask for a second from
baba counselor arthi thank you very much
okay so firstly i'll ask the questions
from either the babe or mid-suffolk
members so starting with with baber
any baba members have any questions on
this paper
okay any mid-suffolk members have any
questions at this stage before we move
into debate
uh i'll then ask the chairs of uh
scrutiny
if they have any questions so firstly
councillor mclaren do you have a
question
thank you chad
sorry tell them what happened uh
thank you chair um
i would like i'm not sure why i should
address the question too
but it the report talks about
community engagement i'm the ward member
for holbrook
what was the holbrook sports centre and
nobody
approached me to ask my view
which i think is an oversight giving the
dramatic
end to the provision in holbrook
um i'd just like to say that hallbrook
provided a service to the whole of
shotley peninsula
and places like bentley um
eastburghalt and and ipswich
and uh i'm a bit perturbed by the
lack of detail in the report about
holbrook because it had a very dramatic
end at the beginning of the pandemic
there was no consultation with the
people of
of holbrook and the registered members
of that facility
and i think they deserve some
discussion um in
a public discussion in relation to the
facts i have been doing some
investigation over the past five months
into the facts
of the holbrook academy sports centre
and i'm trying to get to the truth and
the facts
on behalf of my residents and i am
unhappy
that nobody has pursued that and if
somebody
on the um in the consultancy that was
asking the questions i would have
welcomed an opportunity
to have participated in giving my
views but i would ask perhaps
babe a cabinet to consider
some sort of public discussion to
recommend some public discussion
for the people of holbrook but in fact
you see it's the whole peninsula
so that's a population of eight and a
half thousand people and i think those
people deserve an answer
thank you chair thank you council
mclaren so i guess the question
is are we able to
have some further engagement with the
communities
around holbrook on the peninsula and
also further engagement with the academy
i don't know fiona or vicky if either of
you fiona can you pick up on that please
yes i'm happy to pick that up um just in
terms of the engagement with
um for the purposes of this refresh
um all parish councils were sent to
questionnaire as were i believe all
schools
um and and any other sports clubs and we
did also host
two all member workshops where um
obviously comments were invited about
um any any of these things and
specifically i can't answer about
the past but um i think there's
absolutely an
action in here around working more
closely with schools
and we'd be happy to pursue that
thank you thank you fiona councillor
thank you chair yeah i welcome this
report i welcome the strategy
as the cabinet member for um community
said action is urgent we need
to come out as we come out in a pandemic
um
but i've got a few queries around still
upland a few queries around woolpid and
elmswood
and i think although these are specific
queries i think they are general across
mid-suffolk so bear with me if you if
you would
um yes so presumably you talk to
stow upland high school and that but
there's there seems to be no community
use agreement between
the john milton academy trust and the
community
which is disappointing we seem to be
able to make absolutely no progress on
that
um so how can mid suffolk district
council assist in negotiating an
agreement
um do you do you agree that
the districts have a role in trying to
ensure such agreements are put in place
if i can turn to the high school grassed
areas
um stow upland falcons football club use
all of the grass space at the high
school
so how will other sports be accommodated
and there are tennis courts which
haven't been used and
have been proposed they might be used
for car parking
so how can they be brought into public
use as tennis courts
or even as a netball or whatever
and i just wonder if there is a greater
difficulty and perhaps somebody can
comment on this
well there is a greater difficulty in
sharing facilities when schools achieve
academy status
our local experience is it is much more
difficult to talk to schools
now than it was say five years ago and
we think that's that's possibly the
reason um
planned housing growth um yes you don't
need to
apply planned housing growth but it's
underestimated for still upland
um there are approximately 700 new homes
planned for the ashes farm development
just across the a14 further 300
allocated in the draft local plan
the table in in the document um
allows for 461 extra homes
i think 1500 would be a more appropriate
figure
so can that can the numbers be
reassessed please
um and then um
there's a general query about the way
that spaces are measured
um i i understand that for elmsworth
ward
it's one of the lowest in the district
of only 0.3 indoor spaces per
thousand residents um
so the number you know counting the
number of spaces very crude
um for instance um in the blackboard
center there are four rooms
um which can be made into a large sports
hall
um so how have they been counted have
they been counted as one
although they've got four separate uses
i think that needs to be
that needs to be looked at not just
there uh but across
the the the the district
is is it not a better way to measure and
by
floor floor space by square meters
rather than number of spaces
um there's one or two uh oddities in the
uh in the report about the blackboard
center which is frequently made
mentioned as exemplary as a community
facility but the table makes it look
otherwise
um emsworld parish scouts have just
acquired more outdoor space to
complement their existing space
because there is an urgent need and yet
um
it's shown as only a medium-term goal
in in the um strategies
um yeah these are all these are all
examples of
of things locally but i think they would
be replicated across the district
and our underlining concern underlying
concern is
that there needs to be offices based
locally to pick up on these local issues
and to update data and to lead on
planning for the future
are there sufficient staff available for
in these and similar roles
to actually get on with some some real
delivery
before the money from the uh coming out
of the pandemic is all spent elsewhere
thank you thank you guys
um fiona or harry uh council richardson
which would use would you like to start
on this
i think yes please i think if i wrote
down
correctly council i think i picked up
four sort of key questions
and the first in terms of working with
schools i completely agree i do think
the district council has a role to play
in that particular space
and in terms of the some of the
specifics that he mentioned i suggest
that might be a conversation that we
follow up with
with officers after um in terms of what
i think were questions two and three
about
um some of the housing numbers and some
of the the measurements
um involved i think because they are
more technical questions associated with
the evidence base i think i need to go
and
and provide a written answer outside of
this meeting because it would we'd need
to speak with slc
um to try and find exactly how they
arrived at some of those calculations
in terms of what i interpreted to be the
fourth question about
staffing um numbers i personally am
confident but i think at the end of the
day that's
a question that i will have to defer to
the chief executives head of paid
services in terms of
the actual staffing for the council i
think i've captured everything that was
asked if there's anything else then
don't please do jump in
thank you chad castle welland
thank you chair yeah um could we just
look at um
one of the concerns is a heavy reliance
on local councils and village halls
and other community links i look through
the objectives 2.2
3.1 3.2 3.3 4.1 4.2 and so on
there's a reliance on on local councils
having a role there do we know that
there are resources
at the local level to make to plan the
projects and to make bids
it's all very well to say the money is
going to be available but
experience across the district is that
it's the
you need the volunteers in order to put
together the bids
in order to get the money for the
project so i think that there's a need
for
i don't whether you call them locality
officers neighborhood teams or whatever
people are going to work side by side
when we're allowed to
uh with the local people to put these
bids together who can't rely on
um on the bids coming in well they'll
come in from
the best resource local councils
and if i can turn to 4.3 which is
support and promote clear safe routes
that enable confident active travel and
so on
um am i right in believing that
that the council has a key role in in
this
work because it is important um not only
to have the facilities but also to
be able to travel to those facilities i
mean it
makes no sense to me that people will
get into a car
to travel half a mile in order to do a
zumba class whatever zumba is
um we need we need people working at the
local level
to to to to help with this and promoting
this
and putting the plans together thank you
that's richardson would you like to yes
thank you
and in terms of the first question yes i
completely agree i think one of the
the key themes that runs throughout this
document and underpins the strategy as a
whole
is the emphasis on needing to work in
partnership with others both
parish town councils with directly with
sport
clubs and groups themselves to help
implement this in practice
so obviously we are a player in this
particular field if you excuse the pun
but on the whole partnerships is a key
aspect of this
um obviously that will involve officer
time from our perspective but we want
this to be
um as open and accessible a piece of
work or pieces of work
um as possible to ensure that what we
are implementing is not just what we
think is the right um solution for local
communities but that they have their own
buy-in and input
um in in shaping how some of these
provision takes place in practice um in
terms of the second question around
um the sort of travel and and
um non-use of vehicles absolutely i
think that's a place where we
we do have a role again that will
involve working in partnership with
suffolk county county suffolk candy
council highways
but also we have our own role to play
with the development of the local
cycling and walking infrastructure plan
which i think we're starting to work on
imminently if memory serves
and we also have a sustainable travel
officer working with us as well
and we've also been engaging with
another a number of groups
um such as love to ride for example
which encourages the use of
um or the uptake of cycling not just for
recreational
leisure purposes but also for the
purposes of just general travel
and more broadly so yes that's i
completely agree that's very important
and
i hope that answers your queries
thank you councillor richardson for
those full responses
right um anyone else have any questions
i've got two hands up there uh
i'm sorry i can't
it's counselor melon i'm sorry i
couldn't recognize you under your mask
sorry castlemelon thank you chad
just a couple of questions um obviously
this strategy
has a number of far-reaching and
strategic objectives
i would like to ask are there the
resources
and that staff and funding to deliver it
and then secondly
on the action plan which is um in
recommendation 3.2
who's going to be involved in developing
this when will it be completed and
and the inflammation implementation
start
could there be some some quick gains at
the early stage
of implementation and will there be key
performance indicators included
thank you thank you castle merlin castle
richardson would you like to
respond yes absolutely thank you
councilman
first question in terms of resources
again for the staffing perspective i'd
have to defer to the chief executives
head of paid services
but in terms of funding i am reasonably
confident that we will have the
financial support available to see this
delivered in full
and partly because of the relative
position that mid-suffolk is in in terms
of we've already as part of the previous
iteration the strategy been able to
invest significant sums of money across
the district
and i see no reason why that couldn't
continue into the future especially
because we've already
as i'm sure the cabinet is aware put a
million pounds behind
the well-being priority that this
council has and we'll be bringing
further information about how that money
is going to be spent
forward over the coming months so i
think that will tie in very nicely with
what was already announced in the budget
in february and then this new strategy
which will also come to the full council
at the end of this month
in terms of the specifics around
the action under 3.2 again i think
that's something i would have to say
is taking up with officers outside of
the meeting because what that section of
the report is talking about is the high
level actions
so we wouldn't necessarily see the
specifics around things like kpis
as part of this document this doesn't um
set out the broader strategic outcomes
and objectives that we want to see
but the more specifics will have to be
taken forward at a later date but i'm
sure we can follow that up with officers
if that's helpful
thank you chair thank you um chief
executive
would you like to pick up on the
staffing question yeah absolutely thank
you
and thank you richardson draw me in
twice i thought the second attempt i'll
come in
um so just in terms of the staffing
position it's a constantly fluxing
position obviously to sit here today and
say we have all the staff we need to
deliver all of your ambitions
wouldn't be correct because you'll
change the ambitions and we'll therefore
have to stretch our stuff and complement
accordingly
having said that we are actively
recruiting at the moment to locality
officers of the type that that council
william referred to
so that should give some confidence in
this regard i don't know whether fiona
would like to come in just to add to
what i've been saying as well
yes so vicky our corporate manager
for uh communities uh has just appointed
to an assistant manager
role for sport and wellbeing and their
role very much should be about taking
forward
this particular strategy and developing
an action plan
and but as has already been said there
will be
they may be leading it and there will be
other offices within vicky's team who
will be supporting
but it is very much a collaboration
between
local councils local sports clubs
and of course volunteers who are
absolutely key and always have been in
in delivering
sport and well-being activities thank
you fiona
councillor mabry you had your hand up
would you like to ask a question please
yes would you come sit on the front here
thank you
i don't i don't think you'll still be
able to hear me or can you
yes maybe yes thank you can i just point
out that
sadly those of us who were behind the
screen could not hear councillor halt
we could not hear um mid suffolk
counsellor for sport either we've
actually
missed out on a lot of what was said
so hopefully i am not repeating um
a question for an answer that has
already been
stated right um
considering i was involved with the the
previous
sport and leisure strategy i found this
really interesting however there are
lots of areas where being pedantic
and there are spelling mistakes there
are also um
names that are incorrect i have never
ever heard
of chilton t-o-n
primary school before council maybe uh
we will pick up on errors like this at
another time but can you just focus on
questions please
well i'm asking where that that primary
school currently is
please that's the first one um
i think the perception has changed for
um
physical activity and i think that does
need to be encouraged
however there are no specifics for the
older
generations and that was mentioned that
there are older
people um within our area
we do have some bowls clubs yes
but there's no been no mention of
croquet and ball
which has been actively um
promoted in areas where i live
so i would take that back um
the other there are lots of questions um
particularly are we going to be
expecting
extra funding for our particular awards
to encourage this
do you want me to go through all the
questions
how many are there probably about ten
you know me counsellor p p three of the
most important please right
okay um
right okay um you
talk about chilton woods
um this is not in the center of sudbury
and
for those older persons who are enjoying
living in the urban area of sudbury for
the reasons that there are facilities
there
such as all the shops walking distance
to
some of the leisure facilities this will
actually encourage
motorized travel so why have
is there has there not been an actual
area in sudbury identified for
such physical activity
um we
this is going to be really difficult to
pick out the real three
there are also um points within the
um within the consultation that talks
about
all sports halls on education sites
they are not acton village hall is
actually a sports hall
however that causes us severe problems
because
if they wish to use it for sports we
cannot use it
for a meeting room so
that also needs to be identified i feel
and my question is
is there going to be the opportunity to
actually split
some sports halls from village halls and
will
funding be available
there is no mention of creating new
wildlife areas which would increase
mental health through the ability of
people actually walking around these
sites on a regular
or regularly and also to encourage our
by
biodiversity i think we could actually
use that within it there was also a
comment
i did hear about cycling it is
definitely too dangerous to cycle on the
roads
um within my ward i'm sure councillor
arthur would also
support this just too dangerous so are
we going to
look forward to new specialized
cycling routes within
all of the wards um i can go on but i'll
stop
thank you very much council maybe
actually i've picked up
six questions so far um
one was facilities specific for the
older generation
second was around extra funding for this
the third was
something to do with additional
facilities in the centre of sudbury
to lessen the need to
travel to the chilton woods development
when it's built
the the fourth was separating
sports halls from village halls and
whether there's going to be any funding
for that
the fifth was around wildlife areas and
the sixth
around specialist cycle routes
i think in terms of numbers five and six
wildlife areas
will probably come under our
biodiversity action plan which
there's a lot been said in that
regarding wildlife areas
we're also embarking on um a cycling and
walking
strategy um there'll be a task of finish
group set up for that
to develop that further so i think that
that will be picked up there rather than
um within this this document although
nonetheless there will be links between
the two i would guess
so in terms of the the other four um i
was
wondering whether either fiona or vicky
could perhaps pick up on
on those four is that possible
i'm happy to start i think you might
need to come in and help
um in terms of extra funding um i think
that's one of the things that we'll be
looking at as the next
phase of the delivery planned so
just to reinforce a point there are some
priority
or high level actions here each of those
higher level actions will have more
detailed actions sitting under them
and then we'll be looking at monitoring
and evaluation
and funding for each of those acts
sub-actions if you like
um in terms of um
sorry i'm just done in terms of the
split between sports halls and village
halls again i think that's something
that we looked at the next stage of work
but
um i think it will it as with schools
it's about
understanding the best management model
for some of these spaces
and facilities and that's on a
case-by-case basis so it's difficult to
answer
specifically and then in respect of
facilities for an older generation
and we've deliberately looked at
creating
a strategy which is about activity for
all
um but no doubt again there'll be
specific actions under the more detailed
action plan to follow which will be
around our older residents and i think
that's the same
answer for sudbury as well whilst
there's some priority action areas
picked out
obviously every opportunity to look at
increasing
leisure spawn physical activity in any
of our places will be
will be picked up thank you fiona
thank you councillor mabry i'm now going
to open up the item for debate
so firstly uh favor members do you does
anyone wish to
contribute to the debate counselor rc
um yeah just a couple of comments
um firstly um
something echoing firstly as a result of
what council mclaren said really and um
also margaret mabry kind of
made a bit of a reference to it and that
is the consultation that's taken place
with members already
and i may have got this wrong but i
thought that the
two councillor workshops at the end of
april were open to all members of both
councils
so members could participate and and
give their views
linked to that because it was a point
that was brought up at those workshops
was the older population and the
deconditioning of them because of covid
and we've probably all seen the effects
somewhere
and that i think is addressed in the
strategy
at 3.3.2 onwards
so i mean that is picked up i'm not
quite sure how much more
councillor mayberry would like to see
done
but it is picked up in the strategy and
um lastly i was just going to comment on
the covering report at 4.2 and echo some
of the things that you said
chairman right at the beginning and that
is
with regard to the the cross council
working group that was set up
i certainly took part in that i'm not
sure how many other members here today
did
but we could not have imagined in 2017
that we would have achieved
so much within four years you
particularly referred to hadley swimming
pool and i agree with you there that is
a massive achievement
but all of the other work that we've
heard mid-suffolk say that they've
achieved
in their district and the work to the
kingfisher that you've referred to as
well
i mean i really do think we've done
incredibly well over the last four years
and that's full credit to the cabinet
members involved and the
staff that have made it happen so thanks
to them
thank you council arthur yes and and i
know that the communities in
in sudbury and hadley uh certainly
appreciate that that investment and what
baber is doing for those towns
councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman yeah i i agree
with councillor arthi
um i also was involved in that review
that we did
the strategy in 2017 and we have we've
come a huge way
and it's not just in actions it's our
approach as well it's really really
improved over
the last few years i feel this refresh
is a very
positive approach and perhaps today
we've
tended to talk more about the next
stages of the strategy rather than the
document itself
although relevant relevant will
certainly be discussed when we get to
that particular stage
in regards to sudbury we mustn't forget
the kingfisher in sudbury that provides
many many facilities not quite so many
during covid i will admit because
they've been closed for some of that
time but once they get up and running
completely they will be providing a lot
of facilities for all age groups
including uh the more older in our
communities so we mustn't forget that we
have got that right in the center of
sudbury thank you mr chairman
thank you guys osborne does anyone else
in
a wish to cancel the halt yeah just like
to mention the
whole side of things and i think it does
highlight within the report
the sort of we rely on that on the
sports centers to provide
the facilities and yet we have no direct
control over them obviously so the
engagement we have them in
with them is key but at any time they
could
pull that and i think we have to when
looking at this
almost have a provision should that
happen i'm not quite sure how we go
about it but if those sports centers
pull the plug
then we are left really in a big deep
hole with a lack of facilities and i
think that's
that's the one difficult thing i can see
in here that to try and get over
how do you negotiate do we take a
contract do we take a lease do we take
some sort of a
legal commitment i don't know but it it
will leave a big hole if
for instance in in in cornado and
sudbury both schools were to say no
you're not going to use them when i
opened to the public
thank you council hall i think that that
that clearly points to the fact that we
do need
extensive and and um full dialogue with
with those educational establishments
and um
that is part of this strategy so
that that basically is the mitigating
approach to that
and um we will have to work as hard as
we can with
with those um educational establishments
that
are currently providing facilities and
and also those that could in the future
thank you if there are no further
comments from
baber then i'll move over to mid suffolk
to any mid-suffolk members
councillor flatman first and then
councillor fleming
oh thank you chair um i just want to
reiterate what officers have said
and counsellor arthur this is a high
level strategy
the delivery plans are to come if we
were going to mention
every village in every ward
we'd be well how long would the strategy
be we can't do it it's all to come
and that you know we've taken on loca
we're going to have locality offices
they will be working on the ground with
the volunteers
we will deliver some of this in our
communities we are working with our
supply
with our contractors at the leisure
centres
to deliver some of this in the community
um you know it it's not going to happen
tomorrow but there's some quick
wins coming but watch this space
thank you thank you council flatman
i totally agree with that castle fleming
yes thank you thank you chairman um
yes i absolutely welcome this strategy
and
i think it's it represents a fundamental
shift in how we think about
sport and leisure and how we intend to
invest in it which is the most important
thing
and i just want to pick up on a couple
of points
that people have made
councillor mellon raised the issue of
funding
because this as councillor flatman says
is a strategic document
and funding in the long term has got to
be so
important and i just
hope that we can engage actively with
our partners
to get enough funding for the long term
to sustain
the intentions of this strategy and i'm
talking about partners like
the health service sectors
like the ccgs
primary care we've got a major review of
health and social care coming up with
the white paper
recently issued and let's engage
actively as districts
in that dialogue so that we can be part
of that
um you know that combined partnership
approach to population health that i
think is so important
um because this will take money and it's
where money actually i think
should be spent um so
i also think that the partnership
working with the volunteering community
sector is so important to make this work
i i just wanted to to say that in
particular that
um it's it's a wonderful strategy but it
does need
um reliable delivery and funding
to to to make it happen thank you
thank you council flaming castle
whitehead
thank you chairman i'll be brief um i
commend this very detailed report and
clearly from paragraph 4.2
residents can see the level of
investment made today by both councils
we've set aside further significant
fundings for 22 22 21 22 onwards
to support our health and well-being
strategy i also welcome the private
investment in gym facilities coming
forward recently
in great blake and stone market which
will also help to fill
detailed shortfalls thank you thank you
councillor whitehead castle brewster
you're next
thank you chair um yes i too commit to
commend this this record and uh i think
it's an excellent report
and uh we'll do the job really really
well when we get down to it and and
get through it um just just a a
bit of information i suppose really but
i noted
that the pure gem in stone market which
was in
in the former oldie building there which
mid suffolk purchased
um was due to be open soon
i can now confirm that it will be open
tomorrow
and i will be at the opening uh
this is a very welcome addition to the
town
as it will be open 24 hours a day
it will provide another source of
activity
relating to our health and well-being
strategy
and also of course the leisure and
physical
activity strategy so
it's it's a very good company and
they've worked
the pandemic held them up otherwise
they'd have been opened some time ago
but they are opening tomorrow great
thank you very much for that
council morley
thank you chad as somebody who was part
of the
original um working party back in 2017
and also on this one
i'm really really proud to see this come
through now this is a
total revamp of the
previous strategy and
i was privileged to be able to go to the
opening of the stone market
new gym um last week or the week before
the kit there is absolutely fantastic
and there's a
regular user certainly pre-pandemic
of of the stone market leisure center
the kit there
it's absolutely fantastic really really
good
and also as a regular user of debenham
sports and leisure excuse me
regular use of debenhams sports and
leisure the the kit there
has also had a total revamp
and debenham leisure centre have also
asked me to pass on their thanks to our
officer team and our communities team
for the support that they've received
certainly over the last 18 months
certainly during
kobe not just in terms of keeping our
communities engaged
but also enabling them to
to carry on supporting the wider
community so they are
dublin leisure centre are really
grateful for for this funding
um counsellor willem
identified the fact that we don't we're
trying to keep
physical activity as well as mental and
emotional spirits high shall we say
and while we don't want to people
driving
as much as we do you do need to bear in
mind if you go to
a zumba class would counsel one of them
obviously admits
he doesn't know what that is but whether
it's zumba or pilates
or hit session whatever it is whether
you're on the treadmill for an hour
cycling home for four miles after you've
been on the treadmill for now
is is quite difficult when you've got
really tired legs
so you know you don't want to be pulling
your workout session because you have to
cycle home
so cycling is really important
but certainly for me the road is too
dangerous to cycle
to devlin leisure center and while we
think of stone market as being quite
flat
in actual fact it isn't if you're on a
bike
it can result in really tired legs thank
you
thank you guys molly does anyone else
have any comment they wish to make
if not and i just want to say a few
words myself and
this is clearly an excellent uh and
comprehensive document
um and i think the the sports leisure
and culture consultancy need to
need to be commended for the work that
they put into this but also our officers
as well
and all of the members that took part in
the workshops
the importance of this is as you've
heard
quite significant for both districts and
also and that that's
i i think brought out on the fact that
three of our six strategic priorities
um are touched by this not just
well-being in terms of improving health
outcomes but the community's strategy
because
it really does or will help our
communities thrive
not just for the individuals and
residents in those communities but also
the volunteers and the community leaders
who will be working together
um and so that that's a huge hugely
important factor for our communities
finally of course the the economic
strategy um
uh that they're clearly objectives there
that this this will meet
in terms of improving our uh economic
performance across the two districts
so that this this really is a very
important
and and very welcome piece of work but
uh having said that
i think it's probably now time we we
moved to the vote on on this members
um so if i may ask for the vote to be
opened on this please
yes chair members if you go to the
uh electronic vote on your app
and scroll down to the blue line the
vote should
be in progress shortly
just a moment it started now thank you
thank you chair that is a seven votes
for
for paper cabinet and nine votes for
for mid-socket cabinet such unanimous
thank you very much thanks um okay so
the next two items
are mid-suffolk only so i'll hand over
to castle and morley
now thank you chair
so the next item is mca 21-10
and it's the needham market uh
neighborhood neighborhood plan
and i'm going to invite the mid-south
cabinet member for planning to introduce
this report
thank you
thank you chairman excuse me
members will by now be familiar with the
format of this report which
updates the cabinet on the progress of
needham markets
emerging neighborhood plan now that the
formal
examination has been completed
the report sets out two recommendations
namely that the
town council will be instructed to
modify their plan
in accordance with the independent
examiner's recommendations
and secondly that subject to
satisfactory completion
of the modifications uh it
it approval is given for the plan to be
advanced
to a local referendum
excuse me again
it's taken a number of years to reach
this stage
um but we have now a plan before us that
in its own words
seeks to give residents a voice in the
sustainable development
of the town as noted by the examiner the
plan
chooses not to make any housing
allocations of its own
preferring instead to leave that to the
district level
but it does at least explain that the
minimum housing requirement for this
area
has already been met through existing
permissions
and through sites allocated in the
emerging joint local plan
instead it sets out 10 policies that
look at the mix of house types needed
good design employment and town center
opportunities community infrastructure
heritage and landscape matters
it is therefore very much about putting
in place a foundation
on which the town council may wish to
build in any future
iteration of the plan
as set out in paragraph 4.5 in the
report
where the examiner has found it
necessary to make modifications they
are mostly about improving policy
wording
to provide clarity for decision makers
and to retain a suitable degree of
flexibility
so the future development is not stifled
other minor modifications include
bringing the supporting text up to date
in terms of references to the joint
local plan
i'm therefore pleased to be able to
propose the recommendations at section 3
of the report
and urge cabinet to agree that this plan
now be
advanced to a local referendum at the
earliest available opportunity
i may have please ask for a second for
my proposal
thank you councillor council brewster
your second name
thank you very much so we moved to
questions now from uh cabinet members
does anybody have any questions on this
item
do any questions from any other
non-cabinet members no so we're moving
moving to debate does anybody wish to
start us off
councillor fleming thank you
um i thought i should say something
because um i live near needham market
and i go to needham market a lot
and use it it's a wonderful little town
and i absolutely welcome its
neighborhood plan i just want to mention
um the importance of design which is one
of the things this
neighborhood plan does try to emphasize
and i know not everyone in the room is a
reader
of the spectator but on the
latter part of june there was a very
good article about design at a national
level
and how the main
house builders in england are
simply ignoring the pleadings of
districts residents
politicians etc in terms of trying to
really change the
i suppose the architectural approach to
building and design
at um you would call
desk level and really try and
provide housing that is up to 21st
century standard
and it is built for the long term and
that fits
into the areas where um
you know the regional differences in
this country that
residents are asking architects to take
note of
and also to design houses that
local people can buy and live in
i live in greetings and mary and there
are about five
absolutely enormous houses going down
going up at the bottom of my road
um the price that is being asked is
almost nine hundred thousand pounds each
and i i fail to see how we are really
putting into action
um what we talk about all the time so i
would really like to see our
neighborhood plans not just need a
market neighborhood plan
but the neighborhood plans as a vehicle
for
really engaging with builders developers
and architects
to to give us what we're begging for
it's not that we don't want
more houses we do but we want houses
that are nice that are thoughtful and
that are built for the future thank you
thank you councillor so
i'll now ask the governance officer to
conduct the vote for mid-suffolk members
thank you
thank you chair remember if you can open
the electronic vote in your electronic
agenda please
and scroll down to the item
you will see that the vote is in blue
and it should now be in progress
chair that's nine votes for and that's
unanimous
thank you
moving on to item 10 this is a
resolution to exclude the public
which term includes the press and this
is to consider whether
pursuant to part 1 of schedule 12a of
the local government act 1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during these
this item it is likely that there would
be disclosure to them of exempt
information as indicated against this
item
the author of the report proposed to be
considered in part two of the agenda is
satisfied
that the public interest in maintaining
the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information
can i have a proposal from mid-suffolk
please
councillor gord thank you and a seconder
councillor flatman thank you very much
and
if the governance officer could now
conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair mid-suffolk members if
you
open up the vote on your modern.gov app
and scroll down to the resolution you
will see the line
is lit up in blue for voting and the
vote is now in progress
chair that is nine votes for thank you
thank you very much so moving
okay thank you everyone um we're now on
a baba only uh cabinet meeting
mid-suffolk items have finished and so
mid-socket members have now left
so we're now moving on to the next item
which is item nine
on the baba cabinet agenda which is
paper bca2111
which is an update on five neighborhood
plans
in baber and these are neighborhood
plans for ascertain german distant
little welding field
newton and watt field now now ask the
cabinet member for planning to introduce
this item
council arthi thank you chairman yes
it's been a while since
um since i've presented a neighbourhood
plan to you and as you say we've um
we've got
five today and
yes you've identified them as ashington
german distant little walden field
newton and what field i'm particularly
pleased to
to present the little balding field one
which is in my ward
and wanted to acknowledge the work that
one of their councillors tim shepard
has done to bring this to us
i think it was two years ago when i sat
in a parish council meeting
and he said to me i think we'll have our
neighborhood plan before you have your
jlp
and it's been a close thing um but full
credit to him he's right they will
um the all five of the plans
um have undergone their independent
examination
and as set out in the report um your
approval is
sought for each plan to advance to local
referendum
um the the advancement to local
referendum
is really an administrative step um and
at some time in the future
i think we'll be talking about whether
it's actually necessary
um for these to come to cabinet um just
to
sort of okay the move to referendum
the general context relevant to each
plan is set out in section four
and it explains that our officers have
concluded that the council should accept
the examiner's recommendations and
if we agree that today they will be
obliged to publish a decision notice to
that effect
and you ought to note that it's the
responsibility of the individual parish
councils
to modify their plans which will then be
checked
and signed off under delegated powers by
the corporate manager for
strategic planning the timing of these
is
is probably quite good um because
they've been able to
tap in to the evidence that underpinned
our jlp um and they will of course be
coming forward
hopefully at around about the same time
the key stages and a summary of
modifications tonight
with links to the relevant documents and
reports that set out in the appendices
and i trust that these are
self-explanatory
what i can update you with is
that all parishes are committed to
modifying their plans
in accordance with the examiner's
reports so
they've effectively preempted the first
part of the recommendations
before you today so it's the five plans
that i'm asking you to approve for
transmission on to
a local referendum thank you
thank you councilworthy may i have a
second to please from beaver
council busby are there any questions
on these neighborhood plans
cabinet no any questions from other
members
favor presents
thank you chairman um do i have to
answer a question or can i make a
comment
you have to ask a question i'll try and
formulate it then
um it's very pleasing to see these
five neighborhood plans that have come
before
the cabinet today i'd also like to say
that there is always a question
about how these
are completed and the acknowledgement
of all of the work from volunteers i
think is very necessary
and i'm just asking if it is possible to
actually always
comment from the cabinet or
from whoever that
everyone who has taken part not just
perhaps one or two but everyone
who has taken part in these neighborhood
plans
should be commended i think i've got
round the question
thank you yes that is a question
and i i think we all concur with that
that they should counselor artie um yeah
if it's a question i'll give an answer
and that is yes but perhaps we'll to
save our final congratulations
until the referendum is complete and the
plan is adopted
thank you casarathy right um well
i'll now open this item up for debate
does anyone from weber
uh cabinet wish to make any comment
about any of these neighborhood plans
no well then before we go to the vote i
i will just make
one minor comment and um casarathi was
pleased to see the
little holding field membership plan
i'm actually pleased to see the german
distant one um chelmo's the village of
my birth
and it contains pin mill which
uh arguably or certainly i'd argue is
the
most beautiful part of the whole
district so i'm very pleased that
chalmer has got
or is going to go ahead and uh have an
adopted neighborhood plan
that that be very good for the community
there
so having said that um i think i'll now
ask the governor's office
for us to be able to go to the
electronic vote please
thank you chair if members would open
the electronic vote in their electronic
agenda
and scroll down to the item for the
neighborhood plans
the vote is now in progress
chair that's seven votes for that's
unanimous
thank you okay then
moving on the the next item and i'm sure
this is
one that a lot of people viewing will be
interested in
item 10 paper bca 2112
bellevue sudbury the new park entrance
and facilities
now this report is in two parts and we
have part one which is
the open report and appendix a the part
two uh which apprentices b and c are
confidential
um i have noted that actually in the
main part of the report it does refer to
appendix a
as one of the confidential ones but
that's a minor correction there
but um i'll now ask the cabinet member
for economic growth to introduce the
report so council halt
over to you please thank you chair um
all members have had the report in front
of them hopefully have time to read it
and
fully take in its entirety the purpose
of this report is to seek capital's
recommendation to council
it seeks approval in addition to the
capital expansion program to create a
retaining wall structure
new high quality secure and accessible
park entrance
and new cafe stroke toilet block
facilities to changing places standard
at the bellevue park site in sudbury
also
ford funding of essential works until
the capital receipt is secured
including creating the retaining wall
between both sites
design work and work to submit a
planning application on the park
cafe and toilets cabinet resolved
on the 11th of march 2021
up to 100 of the proceeds from the sale
of the adjacent site will be diverted to
ensure the creation
of the new bellevue park entrance cafe
and toilet facilities
we now wish to move forward these works
as the council's committed to enhancing
the park
and facilities within it and better
connecting the park
with the wider town centre
new entrants will be fully accessible
and we are creating an adult
changing places facility within the new
toilets
which will only be the second in sudbury
to make sure bellevue is a place which
would enable all disabled people
to go out with the same dignity as
everyone else to enjoy community life
socialize and travel we have established
a stakeholder group including the town
council and sudbury society
to help us take forward the design and
implementation of this fantastic new
opportunity for
we will also be working with a landscape
architect to come up with a master plan
for the park
to enhance the current experience that
we intend to hold a public exhibition
in the park later in the summer to show
the new proposals
prior to a plan application and look
forward to engaging
with the public on this we want to make
bellevue park an even better place for
sudbury
for our communities now and in the
future and this project
is the first step in delivering on that
vision
the report also includes updated
information on the overall delivery
program milestones and timeline
for the site german
i recommend items in the report
three point one two three four
i'm gonna ask for a second for those
please
thank you council hulk councillor
osborne are you seconding i am mr
chairman i'm very happy to do so
thank you thank you baba members are
there any questions
on any aspect of the report bearing in
mind that if you have questions on
appendices
b and c which are the timeline and the
costs then we
ask you to wait until we go into
confidential session should we need to
but are there any questions so far on on
the report here
if not i just have one quick question
um and it'll be for fiona actually
um the risk referring to the the step in
rights
what would be the consequences financial
or otherwise should those
uh step in rights have to be activated
by the the developer
um yeah i mean they are a last resort to
step in in the event that we don't do
any of the things that are stated in the
contract um but it would be to the value
of the um
retaining retaining wall works which is
i have to just fertilize the exact
amount but i have to be careful about
quoting exact amounts because there's a
lot more detailed design and costings to
be done
but it's for those works thank you
if there are no questions from the
cabinet members are there any other
members
of baber here wish to ask a question
councillor mayberry
um thank you thank you mr chairman um i
have
two if i may um under
3.4 to
be successful this proposal
actually needs planning permission does
this
make the cabinet all of the cabinet
members predetermined
so they cannot they will not be able to
sit on the planning committee please
that's the first question
okay i'll pass over to the monitoring
officer to answer that one i think
thank you chairman um obviously
pre-determination is a consideration for
each and every
individual member to make um however i
can't see anything in today's decision
that would preach term and a member from
a planning consideration
thank you thank you emily council mabry
your next question
thank you for that that answer um
that my second question is considering
the proposal is to put
uh the new accessible entrance
along what will is cornard
and how can safety be assured
at that point in consideration that it's
a very narrow
road and there's not much area to play
with thank you
thank you council maybe um certainly we
will be
uh talking to highways and others but uh
castle hulk do you want to pick up on
that one
thank you yeah thank you chair um i
think it's
a little bit um
incorrect to say it's a long corner road
um i think that's a statement that um
isn't factually correct um it's offset
from corner road yes
but it certainly isn't uh off corner and
as chairs already pointed out any
application
for the entrance will be a planning
process decision
show so all safety issues in that
planning application will be picked up
and checked with highways
and should there be any concerns they'll
be addressed in the application before
it's put forward to members to decide in
a
cabinet meeting i don't know whether i'm
sorry plan meeting i don't know if fiona
wants to add anything to that
no not really council hall i think
you've said it
maybe do you have another um yes i do
actually um
[Music]
in the previous um consultation
that we looked at this morning which was
sport and leisure
there was considerable comment about
the amount of housing that's being
increased in cornard
the road that i'm talking about and
where this entrance is proposed
is actually one of the main routes from
cornard into town
well considering that it gets quite
congested at the moment
and in consideration of the proposal of
new homes that is
coming forward and in consideration that
currently
there is there is not any alternative
travel route
is this not the wrong place to put the
entrance
that's the hold i must say i didn't
think we were here to debate about the
position of the entrance i thought it
was actually about the money to actually
go for with
the process of delivering the entrance
um but
um no it isn't in my opinion
um i think this is um a great scheme and
uh the one in front of you
he's delivering and we as a cabinet have
made that decision to deliver it
and this is all part of the process of
doing it
thank you council hall councillor airs
did you have your hand out
oh there we go
yes thank you very much chair um yes a
lot of people in sudbury are worried
about
the they think they're going to lose
space
and i'm trying to reassure them that
they're not um but i have had
some people concerned about the trees
and from the
um from we had from church and i think
there's
a king crimson maple it's 200 years old
and i'm assured that that will
remain and that um we really are going
to look at this
very carefully as to how much green
space there is is that right
um i will pass over to council holt so
i'm just going to say that i don't know
what you want the only thing
i would like to say before passing over
to fiona then is that
the trees are a matter for the um
planning application by
by churchill for the retirement homes
we're discussing the park entrance here
today
um and our funding of that but um fiona
did you want to
add anything uh well i was going to say
that actually but but but also just to
uh i suppose reiterate what my michael
holt said earlier that um
the uh this is the first piece sort of
piece in the jigsaw
to improve the park so there's a
you know there's other other plans that
we have in terms of looking at a wider
master plan to make the park even better
than it is at the moment
thank you fiona um councillor owen
sorry about that not sure if this i'm
not mentioning any money but i'm just
um mentioning um that i believe it's
horse before the car
in mind that churchill has not got
planning yet
and we shouldn't be borrowing or we
shouldn't be looking at borrowing
any money considering um
when sifko has allegedly lost 12 million
already
we have waited a long time for this park
entrance
a few months a few months after the
planning decision
that would not hurt um that's more more
of a quote that
we shouldn't be looking at borrowing
money at the moment um
and i'm asking the cabinet members to
look at this very carefully
um and uh
and there's another thing the questions
from lee and robert could i have the
answers from councillor mull
sorry councillor holt um
[Music]
sorry on mod calf if you wouldn't mind i
do apologize
if that's all right i can do that you
want
uh the written written answer written on
there so we can then
because we could we couldn't hear i
understand yeah is that if yeah
yes um but uh and and actually the
answer to councillor lindsay's
question uh would have covered the issue
as to why we needed to forward fund this
yes so the full response there will be
provided to you so you can see that
yes please and just just one final
comment councillor
cifco hasn't lost 12 million i said
alleged
i did say alleged yeah that was that was
in the paper wasn't it
yeah we're not here to discuss no no i
thank you right um
where are we yes so the questions debate
i'll open this up for debate now
cabinet members does anyone want to
start the debate
councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman yeah if i can just
say on the point that council owens just
done
i'm amazed you know we get criticized as
a cabinet
and as members for not investing in our
town in sudbury
and here we are proposing to do that
today and
still we're being challenged i find it
very strange
but anyway on the debate side i'm sure
that once this work is completed
people will be able to see the benefits
that this will provide to sudbury and
its communities
it's difficult to imagine at the moment
but when you actually see it physically
in place i know that we will take a lot
of people with us and they will actually
see
the benefits to the town in respects of
the environment in respects of people
being able to use a much more
pleasant area than they currently do and
also the tourism aspect as well and
making it look nice from the town so
um as i've already given my support and
second in this
recommendation again i repeat i think
this is
a fantastic way forward thank you mr
chairman
thank you councillor osborne does anyone
else wish to say anything
casarathi and then councillor mccraw
yeah just um really referencing back to
the
sport and leisure strategy that we
approved earlier on and i said then
um that it actually was
um quite a pleasant surprise that in
four years
we achieved so much um
here we've got a site um that's that's
been
a problem area for 30 years ever since
i've been on the council
and we've had no real solution
throughout
all of that time and now we have one
and so i really just wanted to say it's
full credit to
councillor halt and and to yourself um
for your
um resilience in in the face of
continued criticism
um that we've actually got now plan um
we've got a plan
that looks as though it's going to be
funded
and as um
sorry wasn't it
councillor osborne as councillor osborne
said
um in a few years time i think that
everybody will look back
and and they'll look at this as as a
real achievement i hope so
thank you thank you councilworthy
councillor
mcgraw thank you chair
um i think the answer given uh by
councillor holt
to councillor lindsay's question
describes exactly the reason why we need
to make this decision in front of us
it is something that is a necessary step
it has to be done in a time scale and we
can see in the
first appendix a description of the time
scales involved and they're quite tight
windows in some cases
and as has been referred to by fiona
there are a series of steps to be gone
through and this is
this whatever one thinks this is a
necessary step
we aren't going to do it unless we go
through these steps in the correct order
so i shall be supporting this
thank you councillor mccraw castle busby
okay i think the things that concern me
on here are
we take decisions in advance of knowing
all of the information
for instance we we selected this
scheme before we knew the costs
we only had one half of the equation
which was the income
well they could have offered 10 times
that but if it costs
10 times that in terms of cost then it's
not a very good investment
and i'm concerned that we haven't yet
got
a full schedule of potential costs
the reason i don't think that we should
necessarily be doing this now i
appreciate that whatever scheme we go
forward with there will be works
required to provide a decent entrance to
the front of the park
but we don't know how much work would be
required
if this scheme didn't go ahead there's a
lot of additional
cost involved in sharing up
an area on the park if you're going to
put a four-story building
next to it if you're not going to put a
four-story building next to it then
maybe you don't need retaining walls
maybe you just need to
the the area landscape so that would
make a significant difference
on the cost and we don't
we've never had what i call a clear
comparison of schemes
we get presented with one scheme which
is supposed to be of benefit
which it looks okay in certain ways
but it's not compared to anything else
we don't know we get
information drip fed to us as we take
the decisions on on this kind of
timeline
so what happens if they don't get
planning permission
have we spent the money committed the
money to spending more than we need to
on the
on the on the parks works
can we recoup it do we have to start
again
it just seems to me that we kind of rush
through these decisions
just so that we can say yes we've got
something done we're desperate to get
something done and i think we are
desperate to get something done
but as the person that's supposed to be
in charge of assets and investments i'm
concerned
that we're not necessarily investing in
in a wise way at the moment
uh thank you councillor busby uh i think
council hall
will probably wish to come back on that
i i do understand your concerns
um but we have made a decision
on on how we want to proceed with this
without wishing to reopen the debate
that we had back in march
um we had six options and and we um
chose to proceed with the one that in
our
view met a range of criteria
best of all um and those criteria
weren't just
uh the the the potential income but
crucially one of them was around
deliverability
um and the one we've proceeded with
certainly
um met that deliverability criterion far
better than the others
and and deliverability is key to this
because
as everyone has said we do finally need
to do something after 30 years
we don't want another 5 10 30 years of
nothing happening with this site
simply because we don't have the
the foresight the strength of purpose
um and the ability to make decisions to
actually proceed and do something for
the benefit of the of the town
but i'll pass over to council hawks i
know he he wishes to to come back on
this
thank you um the decision taken in march
is quite clear
of our approach to this and we haven't
differed from that at all
and the funding that you see in front of
you today is to deliver that
yes you have to spend to get costs so
you can't just come up with a figure
out of the sky you have to spend the
money you have to invest in that
there is a cost so yes we forward
spending
um i'm not sure where you've got four
stories from but we'll wait for the plan
application to see if that's correct
um our ambition is to deliver this this
park entrance
and the scheme i believe is is
deliverable and it will be a fantastic
fantastic park
available to everyone with great
facilities for the future
if a plan application was refused
for the churchills then
other funding methods may be sought
we're here to deliver the entrance
we're not here to deliver a retirement
hunt so
the the the entrance is our deliverable
uh item
and that is what we're focused on we've
got to put our own planning application
in
um and that goes through the planning
process equally as does the
retirement living centre so yeah i i
think it's very important that we we
understand where we are and
and we have to if we're going to deliver
this
full fund it and i see no other
alternative
if you want to just park it to one side
wait for the planning process to go
through with
churchill you'll be here in two years
time probably debating the same thing or
not who knows
but i think the park entrance is
something we want to deliver and we can
deliver it and we intend to deliver it
and we're determined to do that
i agree it's it's how much we spend in
doing that
that's my concern if we decide now that
we're going ahead and we're going to
deliver a park entrance which marries in
with the
churchill development then that's going
to cost us whatever it was
a certain amount of money if
that development doesn't go ahead we may
need to spend half
that amount but we're still going to
have to fund it
and that's my concern is that at the
moment we don't know yet what kind of
park entrance
is best for that area if
the churchill development goes ahead
then the one that we're posing now
might be the best one but we don't know
that the churchill development is going
to go ahead
in which case it might be the wrong
kind of entrance it might be the most
expensive entrance that we don't need
and until we know that the churchill
development is the one that's going
ahead
i don't think we should make that
decision we shouldn't commit ourselves
to providing something which is
engineeringly superb when we don't
necessarily need it
i think my response to council lindy
does sum it up and um
you can't get away from the facts
councillor buzzfeed you have to do this
to enable you to come up with a true
costing and that is what we intend to do
come up with a true costume to deliver
this entrance but
to do that you have to spend some money
up front
and that's what this is about fiona did
you want to come in or lee
if i can get my mask off um yes so the
ford funding element
is is not likely to be the the cost of
the
entire works it is as council holt said
um we need to move forward to a detailed
design
and detailed costing process and that
costs some money
in addition um should the
churchill scheme receive planning
consent and then complete
shortly afterwards um we have to be on
site
doing the retaining wall works within
three months and we would not be able to
appoint a contractor in that time if we
hadn't done the planning application in
pre-work so
a lot of the forward funding relates to
pre-work design work
and the planning application process um
the only other point i
i think is worth just mentioning is that
cabinet have already resolved to sell
the area of land
within the red line and this park is the
land that falls outside of that
so it's not for me to say
it will go forward or not in terms of
the churchill scheme but if it didn't
you have still resolved to sell that
area of land
under under the cabinet decision in
march and the land we're talking about
here is the land that falls outside of
that
thank you fiona and and yes one of the
risks actually does address this point
um and uh does allude to the fact that
an alternative
best consideration disposal would be
necessary for that area
should uh the uh agreement the church
will not proceed so
um and and uh therefore notwithstanding
whatever happens there we will still
need to do this work and we
still need to forward fund to meet that
three-month time scale that
fiona has described
so um does anyone else from from baylor
cabinet wish to
make any comment council malvisi
thank you very much mr chairman um
i think this is an opportunity to
remove an eyesore from the center of
sudbury
which then links up with environmental
issues
and well-being issues
it links into the leisure strategy the
solar parts at kingfisher
sustainable travel and i think it's a
very good report and i
highly recommend it thank you
thank you councillor if nobody else
wishes to
to make a comment from the cabinet um
uh all i would say in in summing up is i
i do uh agree with everything my
colleagues have said
um this is our
real first real good opportunity to
to really do something with this site
and provide a new exciting entrance to
the park
open up more land for people to use and
make sure the park
is accessible from the town centre
visible from the town centre
no
sorry and um uh
where was i yes the entrance um it'll be
a wonderful entrance for for the town
and uh will really help um bring new
vitality to the park
it'll allow people to uh more people i
think to
to use the part they'll see that it's
there and and i do understand the
concerns about the
uh the junction and and the highways
access
and clearly all of these issues will be
addressed um
it's not for us to do that now as castle
holt said that's part of the
planning process to make sure that um uh
the the right uh facilities are put in
place
to allow safe access um across that
junction
and um i think this this is this is
excellent
this is our opportunity to to show to
sudbury that we are doing something good
for the town
having said that now i think uh it's
probably time to move to the vote then
so i'll ask the governance officer if we
can conduct the electronic vote please
sorry unless anyone wishes to go into
the confidential session
to discuss the two appendices
no good
thank you chair if members could open
the vote in their electronic agenda
and scroll down to the blue line that
indicates that the vote is now in
progress
chair that is six vote votes four and
one abstention
thank you for that okay thanks members
that that brings us to the
end of today's meeting so next meeting
will be
monday the 2nd of august at 10 30.
thank you everyone
you